I know the hair has seen better day look
like a European men's tennis player
better gir now I don't do that helmet
hi guys there after I totally know now
you know your life is different now but
you've seen the title of this video hope
it's summertime
everyone's getting bathing suits
everyone's trying them on on internet
try and get you to look at their
Jigglypuff and squirtle it's real so I
thought I'm not better than that
participate to make it ranks do one of
these videos where she saw all of these
bikinis on the website called cup she
that were under $20 and none of them
really fit her that well so I
immediately went and bought a bunch from
that site as I have some bathing suits
from H&M forever 21 and somewhere else
let's just get into the bathing to try
on how shall we
I would subscribe to this channel
because this is going to be fun here we
go the first one is this mom from Cup
she it is um not cute I don't know why I
got this one actually it looks a little
bit like cheap hotel wallpaper which is
super cute if he's all girl wearing this
I think it would be safe to assume that
she would do anything for a shot of
tequila things that you probably
couldn't even imagine if you just build
in a mad lib
[Music]
next this cute high-waisted bikini from
forever 21 that was $17.90
I wish the bikinis would become really
popular in like last year and I didn't
know if I would like them so I got a
cheap one just to try it out and it
turns out I don't like them next we got
nautical come on we got some nautical
vibes happening here some tough she is
that was under $20 tops got some zigzags
it is a little confusing and excessive
and this is just standard bikini bottom
it's really want to add a classic classy
bikini to the collection
[Music]
now
Oh sexy pink string bikini can you even
see it in this backdrop this is very
pepto-bismol sheet I thought to stop
with funny because usually in a bikini
the part that some folks wanna see is up
here but this one says none now we're
going to show you this weird underside
of the boob area that no one ever asks
to see here it is this any students um a
lot like relationships I've had just
lots of strings attached
[Music]
next uh kind of fading super a year this
is Billabong so I think this is a little
bit more expensive but I just added it
to the mix because it's a little
different it's like they watch but not
as sexy cuz it's like a high-neck
scenario prude Baywatch
[Music]
and the last bikini in Nepal it's a very
classic bikini silhouette you got your
top and your bottom and gray stripes and
this is from H&M 79 $12.99 this was 30
bucks
altogether it's less than how old I am
but it'll act to like die
nothing says cute fun flirty sexy
bathing suit Tryon Hall like a deep
depressing look at your own mortality
from time to time
[Music]
okay I hope you guys enjoyed this sexy
bathing suit Tryon Hall I know it's a
little bit out of what I normally do but
I hope that you guys enjoyed it all the
same if you did give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to this youtube channel
because I make videos Monday Wednesday a
Friday you can talk to me on my social
medias I'm at great shelving across the
board other than that I don't know it
sounds like someone that's thriving
[Laughter]
copying sexy